first thanks for having me man it's been
a long time I miss you man miss you too
man I feel like um
I want to say the like the last time I
interviewed you interviewed you was uh
on the back of a bus in Tampa Florida or
Tempe Arizona one of those two places
and it was on the smokers club tour
um I don't know man it was a long time
ago but uh with Joey yeah we've had a
couple of like tour bus interviews for
sure the greatest yeah we was just
talking about that too getting back on
the road yeah good times explain to me
because you were kind of breaking down
off the mic a bit yeah
I can't imagine like the high you get
after it's been a while since you've
been on the road but just to create and
put so much you know Blood Sweat and
Tears into your art and then hitting
that stage literally though literally
and then hitting the stage and just
seeing the people sing along seeing the
people react seeing the people come
alive for you what's that like man the
feeling the people
um you know I can't really
yeah we got to get this very clear I'm
not I'm legally blind I'm not blind yeah
you're yeah legally yeah so
um yeah but like I was saying like it's
um
excuse me that's one of the main reasons
why like
we took a while to drop the album like I
said
well so excuse me
Julio anyway um
um you know we was gonna drop in 2020
but you know the pandemic of course and
I wasn't just about to drop an album
just to stream you know I need to go out
and
feel the effect you know for other
people touching people you know shake
hands and really feel the reception
you know what I'm saying and what like
like I was saying like it's performing
for me you know recording is one thing
like you know right writing is writing
creating is one thing is one is one
craft recording is another craft
performing is a whole nother craft so
like
um like I was telling you it's kinetic
like the performance uh
the performance aspect because like you
know like I said
at least one time when I go on tour
every time it never fails I get dog sick
like I I can't do it and then top calls
like you know are you trying to get this
money or what right right you're gonna
let the people down or what right
you know so you know I suck it up get up
get get on get on stage and as soon as I
get on as soon as I touch the stage I am
healed
no matter what you're going through no
matter what physically physically
wherever I am healed completely
because and I know it's be it's a
spiritual thing it's a it's a kinetic
thing for getting the energy from the
people
and reciprocating it obviously and as
soon as I step off of the stage I'm back
sick
right away right away to the bus to go
to sleep right yeah and so it's like you
know you could call it a high but
I I think it's more it's more spiritual
it's more
it's more personal you know what I'm
saying